ciao a tutti sono un imprenditore nel
campo del marketing e della formazione
sono nato a parma ormai quando avevo tre
mesi sono trasferiti a milano oggi dice
sono un immigrato il contrario che
fortunatamente da circa dieci anni vivo
a salerno in uno dei posti più belli del
mondo conoscete la costiera amalfitana
ecco questa è la vista dal nostro
ufficio di solito lo faccio vedere per
far provare un po di invidia
ecco vorrei finalmente usare questo ted
per rispondere alla domanda l'annosa
domanda che mi fanno spesso ma che ci
fai tu a salerno
vorrei farlo con due fotogrammi milano
salerno milano
salerno
in questi anni ho fondato
alcune aziende conosciute ninja
marketing ecco questo è il clima che si
respira tra noi ninja stavamo sul palco
di un evento che si chiama la battaglia
delle idee e ninja academy che è una
scuola di formazione che ha formato
oltre 20.000 professionisti al marketing
digitale ma ecco arriviamo al punto
perché vi parlo di marketing perché mi
occupo di marketing e riflettendo su
perché mi occupo di marketing sono
tornati indietro al mio passato e mi
sono ricordato di quando ho fatto
l'esame di maturità è un simpatico
membro interno della commissione decise
di farmi due domande che mi cambiarono
completamente la vita
la prima domanda è stata qual è la
differenza tra simbolo e segno potete
intanto cercare di rispondere voi la
seconda non contento il professore
giusto per mandarmi al tappeto
completamente la seconda domanda fu qual
è la differenza tra connotativo e
denotativo ecco se qualcuno di voi in
grado di rispondere dopo mi venga a
contattare perché ancora oggi difficoltà
a rispondere forse per questo che ho
deciso di dedicare la mia vita a
studiare i simboli più potenti nella
società che sono i brand ho scritto due
libri marketing non convenzionale e
creates qualcuno sa letto per caso
cliente progettare idee contagiose
rendere il mondo migliore
ho due bambini sono sposato ho due figli
micol sofia di tre anni e mezzo ed enea
circa un anno o 4.500 amici su facebook
circa faccio al surf da onda questo è il
massimo che riesco a fare mio non è
stato il fotografo è stato
fortunatissimo ho preso un unico momento
in cui sulla tavola nonostante il mal di
schiena e sogno di vivere a bali o
perlomeno di stare per un bel periodo a
bali per imparare a fare surf o una
macchina o sud di cui mi vergogno un po
perché è piuttosto inquinante però
purtroppo quando sono nati bambini la
prima cosa che ho fatto ho cambiato la
macchina aveva una cabrio che mi faceva
sentire molto più figo e giovane però
dovuto cambiarla purtroppo
ecco perché vi racconta tutte queste
cose perché spesso noi ci raccontiamo
attraverso delle identificazioni tutto
quello che vi ho detto sono delle
identificazioni che mi permettono di
spiegarvi chi sono attraverso gli
oggetti che possiedo le cose che faccio
esiste un espressione sanscrita che è
netine ti significa né questo né quello
questa espressione vuol dire bene usata
spesso per spiegare termini religiosi o
spirituali per esempio il buddha non e
causano un effetto netine t ecco anche
voi probabilmente vi definite con le
vostre identificazioni con gli oggetti
che comprate con le persone che
conoscete soprattutto col vostro lavoro
in realtà non siete né questo né quello
fortunatamente non siamo gli oggetti che
possediamo ma non siamo neanche i
problemi che abbiamo le nostre
afflizioni le nostre malattie
ecco il marketing fino a oggi ha
utilizzato questa identificazione per
venderci dei prodotti questo punto il
marketing è quella scienza che essere
per vendere prodotti ci ha mandato un
messaggio messaggio molto semplice che
noi siamo quello che possediamo
e il messaggio sotto di fondo è sempre
stato un messaggio molto frustrante che
tu non sei abbastanza per cui tu devi
comprare qualcos'altro per essere quello
che ancora non sei
e così siamo corsi al supermercato
abbiamo comprato l'ultimo gadget
tecnologico
siamo andati dal chirurgo estetico
abbiamo comprato finalmente la macchina
che sognavamo
abbiamo fatto la vacanza dei nostri
sogni magari solo per raccontarlo ai
nostri colleghi
esistono delle tecniche chi di voi
conosce la meditazione fa meditazione
esistono delle tecniche di meditazione
che servono a distaccarsi da le nostre
identificazioni quindi a capire che noi
siamo molto di più non siamo il nostro
corpo non siamo gli oggetti che
possediamo non sanno i nostri problemi
ecco io vorrei parlare oggi di questo
dello stato di coscienza e farò
riferimento a un uno dei più grandi
filosofi e psicologi contemporanei che
che wilber
che ha scritto breve storia del tutto
ecco che wilber spiega che esistono due
aspetti della coscienza lo stato di
coscienza e lo stadio di coscienza
avete presente quando vi sentite
particolarmente presenti coscienti vi
sarà successo di provare un particolare
amore particolare apertura per gli altri
ecco quello è un momento di innalzamento
dello stato di coscienza ed è facile da
capire molti donella hanno provato
qualcuno raggiunge anche l'illuminazione
lo stadio di coscienza invece è come una
matrice c'è siamo immersi in questo
stadio di coscienza e non ci rendiamo
conto
dipende dalla cultura dalla società in
cui viviamo
dipende anche da il livello evolutivo in
cui siamo come persone come individui
immaginate l'acqua ai pesci non si
rendono conto di stare nell'acqua fino a
quando non vengono non vengono tirati
fuori un bambino è completamente
egocentrico quando il piccolo è preso
dai propri desideri dei propri bisogni e
tutto per se qualcuno di voi ha dei
bambini piccoli è difficile insegnargli
a condividere soprattutto quando sono
molto piccoli
poi imparano da mamma e papà imparano
ciò che è bene e ciò che è male
imparano a condividere i giochi imparano
la cultura
infine crescendo diventano persone
indipendenti sono anche in grado di
sostenere ed aiutare gli altri
ecco immaginate quindi lo stadio di
coscienza come qualcosa che si amplia si
evolve e può passare da uno stadio
completamente egocentrico in cui siamo
l'unica cosa che per noi è importante a
uno stadio etnocentrico in cui il nostro
la nostra coscienza si allarga le
persone intorno a noi alla nostra tribù
alla nostra al nostro piccolo gruppo di
appartenenza a volte la nazione il paese
il gruppo etnico fino ad uno stadio
mondo centrico in cui sentiamo di
abbracciare tutta l'umanità tutti gli
esseri viventi allora in quel caso tutte
le persone anche di altre razze
religioni sono uguali a noi fino ad
arrivare ad uno stadio
cosmo centrico in cui sentiamo di
abbracciare l'intero universo anche gli
animali anche le cose e perché no anche
altri pianeti
passiamo quindi da uno stato di uno
stadio di eco a uno stadio che oggi
vorrei provare a definire di we go ecco
questo sviluppo dello stadio di
coscienza e anche amplificato dalla
tecnologia
conoscete il concetto di internet delle
cose del prossimo stadio di internet il
collegamento tra noi e tutti gli oggetti
ecco questo questo internet delle cose
si sviluppa nell'internet larry fink
l'internet di tutto messia sa e siamo e
saremo sempre più connessi con gli
oggetti intorno a noi attraverso i
nostri device attraverso il guerra ball
ovvero gli oggetti che indossiamo saremo
sempre connesse alla nostra macchina che
sarà sempre più intelligente saremmo
connessi alla casa e potremo ricevere
tutta una serie di informazioni
dall'ambiente che aumentera il nostro la
nostra coscienza
la nostra capacità di processare
informazioni
esiste un concetto giapponese che dice è
show funi unicità dio ambiente
noi siamo collegati la nostra
interiorità profondamente collegata con
l'ambiente quindi interiorità e ambiente
sono due cose ma sono in realtà la
stessa cosa
quindi c'è una correlazione quindi se
cambia il nostro quello che è intorno a
noi la nostra capacità di percepire le
cose cambiano anche dentro e quindi
arriviamo a un'espansione del nostro io
attenzione però che non è un'espansione
del nostro ego non facciamo l'errore che
che fa trump quando dice mostrami
qualcuno senza un ego ed io vi mostrerò
un perdente
e quindi parliamo di marketing
transpersonale che cos'è il marketing
transpersonale beh se c'è un espansione
del io non possiamo continuare a vendere
prodotti alle persone che fanno male
alle persone che fanno male all'ambiente
ma in realtà il marketing si è sempre
evoluto secondo l'evoluzione della
società ed è difficile proprio perché
siamo immersi in questo in questa
matrice per noi comprendere che c'è
un'evoluzione ma se vi dico che fino
all'avvento dell'agricoltura il
cannibalismo era una pratica comune e
fino all'avvento della società
industriale la schiavitù era accettata
ed è stata abolita solamente in 100 anni
negli anni settanta netta roddick ha
formato affondato quella che è un
azienda che si chiama the body shop è
stata la prima a vendere prodotti
cosmetici non testati sugli animali
oggi dal 2013 esiste una legge europea
che vieta di testare sugli animali
i prodotti cosmetici le materie prime e
il prodotto finale
questa è l'espressione che fa una donna
quando guarda dentro una borsa di pelle
in una campagna creata lanciata da peta
l'associazione animalista in australia
per sensibilizzare sui temi del
dell'animalismo e campagne come queste
sviluppano una coscienza e una
sensibilità rispetto a questi temi così
come in qualche modo se volete gli stili
alimentari che dilagano
conoscete qualche vegano
questa è una campagna degli anni 30 una
marca di sigarette pensate venivano
usati i medici come testimonial per dire
che si poteva fumare perché le sigarette
non facevano male alla gola
oppure si diceva mamma prima di
sgridarmi fatto un bel tiro di sigaretta
si usavano le donne e bambini
i medici nel 64 su quattro ruote veniva
pubblicata una campagna che diceva che
sa che si poteva bere birra anche al
volante che era la bevanda più sicura
anche guidando questo signore invece
nils bohlin che è stato ha salvato
milioni di vite umane perché pensate ha
inventato la cintura di sicurezza a tre
punti e la cosa importante questo
designer assoldato da volvo ha inventato
qualcosa che ha cambiato completamente
la sicurezza delle automobili
proprio perché è stata regalata da volvo
con un brevetto aperto a tutte le case
automobilistiche
recentemente è scoppiato il caso
dell'olio di palma che un ingrediente
utilizzato fino a oggi nell'industria
dolciaria che si è rilevato si è
rivelato probabilmente nocivo e quindi
coop ha deciso di ritirare tutti i
prodotti che contengono olio di palma
dagli scaffali
lo dicono studiosi ricercatori come
jeremy rifkin che parla di questo
aumento del cerchio dell'empatia la
civiltà dell'empatia ma anche steven
pinker che parla del declino della
violenza
pensate lui dice siamo realtà nella
società più pacifica mai esistita
una recente ricerca di nielsen ci dice
che una persona su due è disposta a
condividere beni e servizi con la
comunità è sempre una persona su due è
disposta a pagare di più per avere dei
prodotti sostenibili
ancora una persona su due taglia il
superfluo e decide di comprare solo
essenziale e addirittura sei persone su
dieci sono convinte che la maggior parte
delle malattie sia dovuta a una
sbagliata alimentazione ecco vorrei
citare maria montessori per introdurvi
la storia di un gruppo di mamme un
gruppo di mamme a salerno nella realtà
locale cui vivo che ha fondato
un'associazione che si chiama orme di
parodi queste mamme perché secondo me
sono la fotografia delle persone che
comprano oggi no
nel market si chiamano le responsabilità
acquisto quelle che una volta si
chiamavano consumatori che consumano
ecco queste mamme
secondo me sono dei creatori sono dei
creator a un approccio critico al
consumo hanno fondato un'associazione
che si chiama orme orme è uno spirito
greco che rappresenta la motivazione
interiore
la motivazione del bambino a crescere a
imparare senza premi e punizioni queste
mamme valutando che a salerno non
esisteva una proposta educativa
interessante hanno deciso di creare e di
fondare una scuola montessori a salerno
certo lo hanno fatto insieme alle
istituzioni si sono appoggiati al miur
era stato una loro iniziativa e quindi
vi dicevo sono mamme che in tutti i
campi dalla alimentazione che predilige
cibi naturali basso consumo di proteine
animali all'utilizzo di giochi che
spesso vengono vengono usati soprattutto
dei giochi ecologici alle forme di
apprendimento e libri che fanno leggere
i bambini a il tipo di approccio alla
salute dei propri bambini al rapporto
con l'ambiente
ecco stanno cambiando e chiedono il
cambiamento in tutti questi campi
e allora il marketing cosa deve fare il
marketing oggi deve collaborare con le
persone più innovative alle persone che
chiedono il cambiamento deve collaborare
con queste persone per creare prodotti
migliori perché se l'io si espande e
nascono nuovi bisogni trans personali
vuol dire che vanno oltre individui
cominciano ad abbracciare tutte le
persone ma addirittura gli animali
l'ambiente
allora la risposta dovrà essere una moda
etica nei cibi più salubri prodotti che
rispettano le persone e l'ambiente
l'azienda alla fine diventa un azienda
simbiotica passa da essere un'azienda
incentrata sul prodotto quindi sulla
produzione a un'azienda che si basa
sulle persone come singoli individui e
quindi sulla personalizzazione sulla
fidelizzazione a un'azienda
quello che sta tenendo oggi che viene
oggi che si rivolge ai gruppi sociali e
quindi che cerca la relazione con le
persone fino ad arrivare in questa nuova
fase transpersonale a un'azienda
simbiotica che cerca di vivere in
simbiosi con le persone e con l'ambiente
oggi il brand deve essere un sol maker
kottler dice e significato alla proposta
di valore del nuovo marketing e quindi i
brand diventano quasi degli quasi
diventano di incoraggiamento
esistenziale e spirituale per le persone
cominciano a dire finalmente non più tu
non sei abbastanza ma dicono diventa
tutto quello che puoi essere questo
viaggio lo dobbiamo fare insieme
lo dobbiamo fare insieme e noi che ci
occupiamo di marketing noi consulenti le
aziende ma anche voi che siete le
persone che comprano i prodotti e che
quindi possono chiedere alle aziende di
realizzare di vendere prodotti più
salubri più sicuri più etici più
sostenibili per le persone e per
l'ambiente
grazie
mirko pallino